vous avez entendu parler d'une contrée
lointaine et d'une malédiction mais vous
connaissez pas la véritable histoire
et bien et bien je dois
aussi offrir un cadeau à cet enfant
bush et du son la
dans son bulletin
élu s'il est elle pourrait presque
inspiré de la compassion
la fim petit curieuse amené la mort je
sais que vous êtes là
n'ayez pas peur je n'ai pas peur de toi
alors montrez vous c'est toi qui
pourrait avoir peu
toutes les autres fai peuvent voler
pourquoi pas vous j'avais des ailes
autrefois
partout
on les a volés
elle fait partie de ce monde la haine et
la vengeance
y en a
là toutes les créatures de l'ombre
est ce vrai faites-vous maléfique